أنت تعرف دونالد ترامب أم
وتحدثت معه كثيرًا ، لقد تحدثنا في الواقع في
المقابلات السابقة عن
تلك المكالمات الهاتفية الشهيرة
، فدائمًا ما
قال أشياء لطيفة عن فلاديمير بوتين
إنه دائمًا حتى بعد
غزو أوكرانيا أعتقد أنه  قال إنه عبقري
يقول أشياء ،
ما الذي تعتقد أنه لا يفهمه
عن بوتين ،
ما الذي ستقوله لدونالد ترامب
لمساعدته على فهم بوتين الذي تراه
أعتقد أنه كان لديه ما يكفي من الوقت
لفهم من هو بوتين
أعتقد أنه  كان جالسًا في مثل هذا
المنصب الرفيع حيث لا
يمكن حتى
عدم
إدراك
أنه
الخصم من حيث القيم
لشعبك ولديه كل ما لديه من
بيانات استخباراتية لهذا البلد لإنشاء
ملف تعريف نفسي ، وبالتالي
تحتاج في هذا المنصب  لفهم من
هو بوتين الذي يسعى إليه وما هي
الخطوات التي سيتخذها للوصول إلى هناك ، لذلك
فوجئت أنه حتى بعد
بداية الغزو الكامل
دونالد ترامب
ذكر أشياء قلتها للتو أعتقد
أنه يحتاج إلى النظر
إلى هذا
أه ليس فقط من وجهة نظر أن
هذا تهديد لأوكرانيا جيدًا.
إنه يحتاج إلى النظر إلى
الموقف
دون كما نقول النظارات الوردية ،
لا أعرف ربما كان بحاجة
إلى هذا للترويج لسياسته الداخلية لإظهار
أنه مستعد للتفاهم
مع رئيس روسيا